they're giving me another flow rate okay
by the way flow rates are often they
come up with these questions a lot
because flow rates by easier measure
okay so that's why it comes up now the
flow rates given by minus that so just
to expand that because that's what's
gonna be useful to me what I hated you
for a chair in a second
this is a constant that's what I get
okay
now even though I could have written
this as 10 t minus 400 I think they're
putting them by this sign out there in
the front to indicate to you water is
falling out right so general this thing
is like their volume is decreasing okay
does that make sense so that's what
that's what a negative gradient means a
negative rate of change in this case
where V is the volume of liquid into
this will at time T seconds okay and
it's it's also I should learn it's on V
cubic centimeters really go watch out
for units okay
initially the vessel contained eight
liters of liquid okay
cubic centimeters leaders what's the
relationship a thousand right
this isn't physics so I don't need to
worry about your pressure temperature
those kinds of things I'm just going to
go 1,000 cubic centimeters for one thing
up okay so since I've got eight liters
that's
what finding out of liquid in the vessel
after 10 seconds okay right that's how
we got this
so I'm previously in a second if I want
to work that volume and I know how
Ballroom is changing over time that's my
cue to think okay that's a different
shape right so here's what our function
is what's the primitive going to be good
when you see a constant you just chuck
the Chuck the variable look okay yeah
good because we have to divide by that
power
watch the constant okay now in this case
because we can't given this piece of
information here right this vid is just
like in that previous exercise when
they're like okay these are functions
that have passes through these
coordinates or F of 1 equals 4 something
like that so what this is is the piece
of information which allows us to
actually evaluate C right so I'm gonna
say when T equals 0 V is equal to 2000
yeah I'm gonna pop that in here okay and
by the way it's critically important
even though you're probably guess you
can see like the previous example right
wait you put t cause you're here they're
all gonna vanish you're just gonna end
up with this is gonna be our value for C
okay but you can't come skip this step
okay because you gotta show where how
what process did you go through to
actually get that value C so I've got my
8,000
see and that's enough
now I've established it on that basis I
can say that's what C is okay so now
I've got an actual phone function for V
now I come back to the question which
was what's the volume after 10 seconds
yeah okay so after 10 seconds where T
equals 10
now just like in calculus right and we
were talking about you know if you're
good at a differentiator or if you're
gonna find a stationary point or
whatever you should explain what you're
doing these lines here that it gets your
box but it's super useful okay they they
put they make your a make your work
incoherent okay rather than just random
equations that come out of your head
it's really contra bucket road work
exactly
so T equals 10 evaluate some minus 4,000
plus 5 so you get
for time okay kids said it is what they
want to find the amount of liquid since
it's a liquid I guess that's why they
wants to connect to leaders so I guess
you'd say for the hoppers
right now there's a just quickly there's
a second part to this question what's
guess to check so the next question is
how long does it take since water is
flowing out right how long does it take
to hipty if you started with eight
liters okay so for the vessel to be
empty and I write this down right for
the vessel to be empty e equals zero
okay so don't let this statement to just
sort of pop out in the middle yeah so
now that I have this that's where this
next equation is gonna come in all right
so I've got minus 4 100 T plus 5t
squared it's 8,000 okay I'll put this
out the front in a second to make it a
bit more clear as a quadratic and I
guess I should divide through by five
okay so that's gonna leave me with T
squared minus 18 plus 16 okay what's the
factorization
okay so T is equal to 40 and when they
say check by substitution it's a bit
silly only what you do is put this back
into your equation for V and verify that
our noble Bobby okay so I would say
after 40 seconds it's empty
well yeah so in this in this particular
example I don't need to because my only
solution is positive but it's a very
very common thing what Jesse's mentioned
too
suppose this was slightly different the
numbers were off and the factorization
you get is something like oh I don't
know T plus 20 t minus 40 let that equal
to zero okay this is really common this
comes up all the time
okay so what you're going to get from
here as we said this before right if
there are two solutions so this you
should take note of it don't don't just
ignore one okay so you should say minus
20 or 40 and then you say but T is
greater than zero okay at least in this
case it is you know sometimes you get a
question of this so this will come up
more in the next 12 months they'll say
things like 9:00 a.m. is T equals zero
okay so they'll say look this is just a
relative thing there is such a thing as
t equals minus 1 or minus 50 or whatever
in this situation right well they might
say the year 1995 is T or 0 so again
negative time has a meaning in this
right here it doesn't in our particular
question is trivial anyway but do watch
out for they gave time when we get to
questions like that I'll show you how to
do with them okay